head to a Youngstown Ohio and Brian
you're on with dr. Wallach Oh Brian
you're on the air
hey dr. Wallach yes sir thank you I
wanted to thank you for coming up to
Michigan last week I had a awesome time
with a lot of fun one oh yeah I want to
apologize for cracking my knuckles Qi
Monday night Oh in the front row yet
yeah okay what's up I got a friend of
mine who has an autistic son and I
wanted to see what can i how can I
direct them to help with that or is
there a way of course basically what you
need to do is get them the new CD out
called serial killers serial killers
okay and you get a hold of that CD
serial killers and it goes into why we
have so many kids with autism a DD and
ADHD you can get the book rare-earths
have been cures so that book goes into
that subject also okay and basically
it's a combination of mineral
deficiencies omega-3 essential fatty had
deficiencies and also too much sugar in
their life so number one they need to
get on the all-mighty 90 appropriate for
body weight not age with body weight and
as one dose of the healthy starter pack
per hundred pounds of body weight little
kids of course will get if they weigh 50
pounds it's a half a dose a day and then
you would cut it in half so they get a
quarter of a dose of breakfast quarter
betos a dinner if they weigh 20 pounds
and so on just keep reducing it's
appropriate for their body weight how's
it going to give them the omega-3
essential fatty acids I was going to get
mauled and known essential nutrients
minerals vitamins amino acids and there
was a mega three essential fatty acids
but also they're incumbent to make sure
they get animal proteins and good fats
with each meal eggs red meat chicken and
fish nothing fried no processed meats
because they're loaded with sugar and of
course you have nitrates and nitrites in
them and they have to go on a
gluten-free diet that's why I want them
to get that CD serial killers they
cannot have wheat barley rye oats they
cannot have fried foods they cannot have
a gobby syrup maple syrup corn syrup
they cannot have Kashi granola
it cannot have energy bars everything
we're sugar in it they got to give up
for snacks they have to have either a
hard-boiled egg or they can have the
mixed fancy nuts
not containing peanuts because peanuts
are carbohydrates you have to give all
that up and then it almost always kids
with simple autism of which like 98% of
it is just simple maybe 2% kids are also
born with Down syndrome they're born
with some permanent damage to the brain
because a mother was not taking any
vitamins minerals in the early stages of
pregnancy so the brain did not form
properly either biochemically or
anatomically and so there's a little bit
of that but mostly when kids have autism
they're born normal and to become
autistic at about one and a half to two
three years of age that's because are
shifted off of a formula or breast milk
onto Fruity Pebbles and apple juice or
pop-tarts and Welch's grape juice or
Sunny Delight and a goes with syrup on
it right so got to get all that sugar
out of their life all the carbs are
their life all the wheat barley right
and oats out of their life all the fried
foods or the processed meats all the
carbonated drinks with meals then get
them on the 90 essential nutrients
appropriate for body weight get the
books let's see here errors Ben cares
and get the CD serial killers